hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live lange wurden sie gefordert jetzt
bekommt die Ukraine Schützenpanzer aus
Deutschland 40 Stück Typ Marder hat die
Bundesregierung zugesichert es sind
keine Kampfpanzer aber zusammen mit
panzerlieferung aus den USA und aus
Frankreich und der Patriot
Luftabwehrraketen Batterie die
Deutschland auch versprochen hat zeigen
die Waffen der Ukraine weiter
Unterstützung aus dem Westen
erwartbar kommt scharfe Kritik von
Seiten Russlands so unter anderem hat
sich die russische Botschaft in Berlin
heute geäußert verurteilt diese
Lieferung auch darüber wollen wir heute
sprechen aber vor allem über die Frage
was bringen diese Panzer so verändern
die Panzerlieferungen aus Deutschland
Frankreich und den USA den Ukraine
kriegt das ist heute unsere Frage denn
in Deutschland wurde lange gezögert
Panzer liefern Ja oder Nein Details und
warum sich die Regierung dazu
entschieden hat ein Beitrag aus Berlin
nun von Andrea Maurer
die Pläne der Bundesregierung werden im
Laufe des Tages konkreter die bis zu 40
schützenpanzermörder sollen aus
Beständen der Bundeswehr und der
Industrie kommen außerdem hat der
Kanzler ein Patrick Luftabwehrsystem
zugesagt von dem es bislang hieß es
stünde keins mehr zur Verfügung wir
haben die veränderte Situation a dass
die Amerikaner ihrerseits eine solche
Lieferung ermöglichen da geht es wieder
um den Punkt den ich immer wieder sage
dass wir keine nationalen Alleingänge
machen und eben auf Bitten der
Amerikaner haben wir geguckt ob wir noch
helfen können und haben einen solches
Patrick System jetzt dafür aus
Bundeswehrbeständen wenn wir zur
Verfügung stellen kaum sind Marder und
Patrick beschlossen wächst der Druck
noch mehr zu liefern schwere Kampfpanzer
etwa wie den hochmodernen Leopard 2
Forderung kommen heute aus der Union und
Teilen der Ampel
der zweite Schritt muss auch kommen
nämlich dass das
Selbstverteidigungsrecht der Ukraine
unterstützt wird mit der Lieferung von
Leopard Panzern der Krieg ist Horst ganz
bitteres und tragisches und man muss
alles dafür tun um ihn zu schnell wie
möglich zu beenden und wir haben die
Chance in umso schneller zu beenden je
deutlicher wir die Ukraine unterstützen
deshalb ist auch bei den Leopard umso
schneller umso besser die linke
Opposition dagegen sieht im Kanzler
jetzt einen getriebenen kritisiert die
Panzerlieferungen das ist ein weiterer
Schritt für Eskalation wo eine
Beteiligung Deutschlands auf einmal in
diesem Krieg wahrscheinlicher wird denn
eins ist ganz klar diesen Krieg mit
einer Atom macht ist nicht militärisch
zu klären das neue Jahr beginnt mit
einer Wende in der deutschen außen und
Sicherheitspolitik gemeinsam mit den
Verbündeten liefert Deutschland nun
sogenannte moderne Panzer westlicher
Bauer hat die ersten Mörder sollen Ende
März in der Ukraine treffen
und ihr könnt Fragen stellen
mitdiskutieren im Stream oder direkt per
Mail an unsere Expertin
Sicherheitsexpertin Ulrike Franke vom
European Council on Forint relations
schönen guten Abend guten Abend Frau
Franke das war jetzt eine Entscheidung
die nun getroffen wurde nach langer Zeit
die die Ukraine das natürlich auch
gefordert hat war das wirklich eine
lange geplante Entscheidung gemeinsam
mit Frankreich oder das Frankreich da
jetzt auch erstmal vorgeprescht ist und
wir nachgezogen sind sind wir da so ein
bisschen hinterhergehängt was ist da
ihre Einschätzung
das ist in der Tat die große Frage also
ist wirkt schon auf mich als sei die
ganze Geschichte nicht so in
Koordination mit den Partnern gelaufen
wie das jetzt aus Berlin gesagt wird der
Grunde sich das sage liegt darin dass ja
Emanuel macron einen Tag vorher nämlich
an Mittwoch ihm gesagt hat dass
Frankreich später Panzer liefert und
dann Tag drauf kam die Deutschen und die
Amerikaner mehr oder Männer zusammen und
sagten sie liefern Bradley und jetzt
eben die Marder ähm wenn es da eine
komplette gemeinsame Absprache gegeben
hätte fragt man sich schon warum hat man
es nicht gemeinsam verkündet so wirkt es
zumindest so als seit Deutschland als
sei Olaf Scholz wieder ein Getriebener
ich weiß es aber auch nicht vielleicht
ist Sie Manuel einfach nach vorne
gepresst und es war abgesprochen es ist
nicht ganz klar aber so ganz so ganz
rund lief das zumindest in der
Kommunikation jetzt dieser Tage nicht
wir sprechen gleich weitergehen dann
noch mehr ins Detail schauen aber kurz
auf die Reaktionen aus Russland und der
Ukraine sprechen mit unseren
Korrespondenten der ukrainische
Präsident hat sich auch zu Wort gemeldet
es gibt einen Ton von Präsident selensky
wir hören kurz rein
ich möchte mich persönlich bei Präsident
beiden und Kanzler Scholz bedanken für
die Entscheidung unserer Verteidigung zu
stärken das ist eine sehr wichtige
Entscheidung wir werden eine weitere
patrick-batterie und starke Panzer
bekommen das ist ein wirklich großer
Sieg für unser Land
fragen wir nach bei unseren
Korrespondenten für Bega ist in Moskau
Tim Kröger ist in der Ukraine in Kiew
für Reaktionen aus Moskau auf diese
westlichen Panzerlieferungen gab es die
jetzt schon politische Reaktion
nein also zumindest aus dem Kreml gab es
heute noch nichts das könnte durchaus
daran liegen dass hier ja Weihnachten
ist und generell nicht so viel
kommentiert wird aber die russische
Botschaft in Berlin die hat eine
Erklärung veröffentlicht und darin die
Berliner Entscheidung als Eskalation
bezeichnet und diese Entscheidung auch
verurteilt Berlin habe da eine
moralische Grenze überschritten die man
besser nicht hätte überschreiten sollen
und das ganze zeige so die russische
Botschaft dass dem Westen nicht daran
gelegen sei eine friedliche Lösung in
dem Konflikt zu finden diese
Anschuldigungen und diese Behauptungen
das ist der immer sich wiederholende
versucht der russischen Seite die Schuld
dem Westen zuzuschieben die Kämpfe in
der Ukraine zu erklären und vor allem
dem heimischen Publikum zu erklären
wieso ist auf russischer Seite zu suchen
Verlusten unter den Soldaten kommt
aktuell ist orthodoxes Weihnachtsfest
das hat Präsident Putin dazu genutzt
eine Waffenruhe zumindest so nannte er
es anzuordnen was will er damit
erreichen Putin
naja das Kalkül könnte zum einen gewesen
sein diese 36 Stunden Feuerpause dafür
zu nutzen die russischen Truppen mit
etwas Nachschub zu versorgen und sie
vielleicht auch da wo es eben nicht so
gut läuft zurzeit besser aufzustellen
aber ich denke es gibt noch eine weitere
Komponente in dieser Anordnung und das
ist der Versuch der Image-Pflege
Wladimir Putin stellt sich da als jemand
dem die orthodoxen Christen in der
Ukraine am Herzen liegen würden der
Ihnen gerne ermöglichen möchte zum
Weihnachtsgottesdienst zu gehen ganz
allgemein als einer der sich kümmert und
das ist der Versuch sich einen
humanitären Anstrich zu verpassen der
aber nur dann funktionieren kann wenn
man außer Acht lässt dass er der
Oberbefehlshaber ist der seine Armee
überhaupt erst ins Nachbarland geschickt
hat
von unserem Hauptstadtstudio in Berlin
hören wir übrigens Reaktionen auf diese
Kritik der russischen Botschaft schakota
labenergy unsere Korrespondentin sorgt
unsere Korrespondentin dort sagte auch
im Kanzleramt sorgt die Formulierung
anscheinend nicht für Beunruhigung nach
zdf-informationen nimmt die
Bundesregierung diese Stellungnahme
lediglich zur Kenntnis das sei noch hier
an dieser Stelle gesagt aber kommen wir
noch mal auf dieses Thema Waffenruhe zu
sprechen Tim du bist in der Ukraine
heute gab es trotz dieser Waffenruhe
aber Luftalarm in allen Regionen in der
Ukraine wie ist die Lage aktuell
also das lässt sich von hier aus immer
schwer beobachten schwer beurteilen wie
die Lage in der gesamten Ukraine ist
aber es ist richtig dass heute nach kurz
nach Beginn der einseitigen Waffenruhe
ist in der gesamten Ukraine Luftalarm
gab das haben wir auch wir hier in Kiew
wahrgenommen dabei ging es ganz offenbar
durch Flugzeuge die über Belarus
aufgestiegen sind aber es ist dann ganz
offenbar doch nicht zu einem Angriff
gekommen es gibt auch Berichte über
Angriffe von beiden Seiten im Süden und
im Osten an der Front aber das sind
Berichte die wir nicht wirklich
verifizieren konnten im Großen und
Ganzen ist es so dass die ukrainische
Regierung sowieso diese Vorstoß Putin
diesen Vorschuss moskauz nicht als Geste
des guten Willens anerkannt hat sondern
dass er als ähm etwas ein ein Werkzeug
sieht womit die Russland Zeit gewinnen
will Zeit um Nachschub an die Fronten zu
bringen um dann womöglich nach dieser
Waffenruhe umso stärker los zu schlagen
das Ganze sei einfach seine Propaganda
und überhaupt keine über so etwas wie
eine Waffenruhe erst dann gesprochen
werden wenn wirklich der letzte
russische Soldat die wir besetzen
Gebiete in der Ukraine verlassen hat ein
Schätzungen live aus der Ukraine von Tim
Kröger und von für Bürger aus Moskau
vielen Dank
und welche Bedeutung unsere Waffe diese
Waffenlieferungen unsere
Waffenlieferungen konkret haben das
können wir natürlich besser analysieren
und verstehen wenn wir auch wissen um
welche Waffen und Panzer in dem Falle
ist konkret geht und was sie können aus
Frankreich wir haben es angesprochen
schon kurz kommen also auch Panzer vom
Typ A mx-10rc aus den USA geht es um den
Schützenpanzer Bradley m2 und aus
Deutschland eben der besagte Marder was
die können und was das im Detail
bedeutet erklärt uns jetzt Stefan reich
der französische spätpanzer amx-10rc
dient vor allem dazu die feindlichen
Truppen auszuspähern und ihre Positionen
zu lokalisieren da der Radpanzer dafür
nahe am Feind operieren muss ist der
relativ leise und schnell bis zur 85
Kilometer pro Stunde im Gegensatz zu
Kampfpanzern ist der spätpanzer leichter
aber aus schlechter gepanzert und damit
anfälliger für Angriffe ganz wehrlos ist
der AMX trotzdem nicht er verfügt über
zwei Maschinengewehre für Flugabwehr und
Nahkampf mit seiner 105 mm Kanone kann
er außerdem russische schützen und
Transportpanzer bekämpfen
der amerikanische Schützenpanzer Bradley
m2 wird eingesetzt um Soldaten ins
Kampfgebiet zu transportieren sechs
Kämpfe haben Platz im Heck beginnt der
Einsatz können Sie den Panzer schnell
über eine Rampe hinten verlassen mit
seiner 55 mm Maschinenkanone kann der
Bradley feindliche Panzer in einer
Entfernung von rund 3000 Metern
bekämpfen zudem ist er am Geschützturm
mit einem Maschinengewehr ausgestattet
der deutsche Schützenpanzer Marder
bringt sechs Infanteristen ins Gefechte
und gibt ihnen Feuer Unterstützung mit
einem Maschinengewehr und einer 20 mm
Kanone mit ihr kann der Marder tief
liegende Ziele wie Hubschrauber
abschießen aber auch Panzer und
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge in eine Entfernung
bis 3000 Meter der Marder ist bis zur 65
km pro Stunde schnell wendig und
flexibel trotz seiner robusten Panzerung
so und jetzt wollen wir zusammen schauen
ich habe gerade eben mal nachgeschaut
bei uns in der App bei ZDF heute das
wollte ich bitte ich euch gerne zeigen
und zwar hier an dieser Stelle können
wir mal gemeinsam schauen wen das noch
weiter interessiert also die Details zu
den verschiedenen Panzertypen das könnt
ihr auch bei uns hier bei ZDF heute
nachlesen da haben wir für euch ganz
viele Details zusammengeschrieben und
wen es interessiert der kann gerne bei
uns in der App vorbeischauen bei uns
hier geht's jetzt aber erstmal wieder
weiter wir können eure Fragen
beantworten mit Ulrike Franke vom
European counsel und fallen relations
ist wieder bei uns schönen guten Abend
vielen Dank dafür und die erste Frage
kommt auch direkt aus unserer Community
von Hans spiesel bei Youtube möchte er
wissen was bringen die Schützenpanzer
die Russen haben doch zu viele
Kampfpanzer also was bringen denn jetzt
diese Panzer die wir liefern
ich würde schon sagen dass diese
panzerin Einfluss haben können also man
muss immer sehr vorsichtig sein zu
suggerieren dass ein Waffensystem eine
Lieferung jetzt die große Wende bringt
selbst bei den Leopard 2 Panzern den
Kampfpanzern wäre ich da vorsichtig aber
jetzt insbesondere auch bei diesen
leichter gepanzerten Systemen trotzdem
gibt das der Ukraine mehr Möglichkeiten
wir haben gerade gehört das sind relativ
flexible System aber gleichzeitig eben
gut gepanzerte Systeme soll heißen es
gibt ja Ukraine die Möglichkeit ihre
Soldaten vorne in das Kriegsgebiet in
das Kampfgebiet zu bringen und zwar auch
eine Art und Weise die eben sicherer für
die Soldaten ist als das was sie bis
hier machen und der Ukraine fehlen
natürlich Soldaten bzw ist die Ukraine
eben auch nicht so zynisch unterwegs wie
Russland und verfolgert ihre Soldaten
nicht auf die selbe Art und Weise
insofern ist das deswegen schon mal sehr
wichtig plus das haben wir auch gehört
in den Beitrag das sind teilweise auch
ganz schön stark bewaffnete Systeme die
können eben auch russische Kampfpanzer
angreifen und auch das ist sehr relevant
für die gegen Offensive also insofern
jetzt gerade auch in der Kombination ist
drei verschiedene Systeme aus bei
verschiedenen Ländern sind die teilweise
unterschiedliche Dinge können das macht
hat schon einen einen Einfluss aber wir
sollten jetzt auch vorsichtig sein nicht
zu erwarten in dem Moment in dem da die
Marder oder die Bradleys auf dem Boden
in der Ukraine ankommen dass ich dann
der kriegt sonst läufig direkt Wende
hier gibt es auch noch Zweifel an der
Anzahl also ob das genug ist Frank
Hochwasser schreibt wenn er jetzt nur
jeweils 30 Stück kommen macht das keinen
Unterschied zur jetzigen Situation ist
eine Annahme würden Sie sagen auch es
ist wirklich eine geringe Menge oder ist
es ist genug naja also mir ist natürlich
immer besser und die Ukraine fragte nach
diesem System schon sehr sehr lange also
ich erinnere mich noch im April war der
Bürgermeister von hier Klitschko in
Berlin und fragte genau nach diesem
mörderpanzern also natürlich die Ukraine
hätte diese Systeme schon gerne länger
sie hätte auch gerne mehr so viele
irgendwie möglich sind diese Anzahl ist
aber auch einfach dadurch begrenzt weil
die Frage ist wie viel haben wir denn
gerade gehört aus dem deutschen Fall
jetzt sollen diese Systeme zum einen aus
der Industrie kommen die haben schon in
den letzten Monaten begonnen diese
Systeme vorzubereiten also wieder
aufzurüsten aber es werden auch Marder
aus der Bundeswehr kommen und das ist
schon interessant weil die Bundeswehr
hat ja von nichts zu viel und ich will
was sagen eigentlich für nichts genug
der Marder wird jetzt noch mal besonders
gefordert weil wir ja auch aktuellen
Ausfall beim Puma haben das heißt der
Marder so eingesetzt werden für die
schnelle Eingreiftruppe der NATO spricht
die Zahl nehme ich jetzt mal an von
diesen 40 dir das ist letztendlich so
viel wie Deutschland aktuell zur
Verfügung stellen kann wäre mehr besser
mit Sicherheit aber 40 Systeme sind 40
Systeme und dann kommen eben noch welche
aus Frankreich aus den USA und ja das
macht dann schon den Unterschied aber
natürlich die Stimme durchaus dem
Zuhörer oder Zuschauer zu dass mehr
sicherlich eine ukrainischen Seite
gewünscht würde und jetzt gibt es auch
noch hier Zweifel in der Community
vielleicht an dieser peu à peu-taktik
denn wir liefern immer wieder ja diverse
Waffen aber es dauert natürlich auch
seine Zeit Rom User Userin schreibt ist
diese Salamitaktik der Unterstützung
nicht nur nicht zielführend sondern
sogar gefährlich und wird langfristig
zahlreich Verluste der Ukraine fordern
was sagen sie das ist eine Kritik die
ich nachvollziehen kann es ist in der
Tat so dass eigentlich seit Kriegsbeginn
und eigentlich auch schon vorher die
Bundesregierung jetzt nicht gezeigt hat
dass sie eine klare Strategie hat man
sagt so auf der einen Seite man will der
Ukraine alles geben damit sie gewinnen
und sich verteidigen können aber es ist
in der Tat so eine Salami Taktiken es
kommt eins nach dem anderen an die der
Grund nehme ich jetzt an oder so wird es
auch kommuniziert dass das so gehandelt
wird ist ja die Sorge von der
zunehmenden Eskalation und auch immer
und das ist gerade in der deutschen
Diskussion ganz wichtiges Thema die
Sorge vor einer möglichen nuklearen
Eskalation danach sieht es aktuell
überhaupt nicht aus aber das erklärt
warum insbesondere Berlin immer da sehr
vorsichtig waren eben nur Stück für
Stück geliefert hat aber es ist schon
richtig dass wenn man diese Systeme
früher geliefert hätte eben insbesondere
auch die Schützenpanzer die ja auch die
Soldaten im Einsatz schützen
das hätte sicherlich auch geholfen
ukrainischen Soldaten dass das Leben zu
retten das muss man sich auch bewusst
machen wann sind denn diese
panzerkampfbereit das habe ich eben
gerade noch in den Fragen schnell
gesehen
ja das ist eine gute Frage also die
deutsche Industrie bei der ja viele von
diesen Mardern stehen die war gut
zurückgegeben von der Bundeswehr die die
nicht mehr brauchte hatte diese Systeme
durchaus schon flott gemacht davon sind
ein paar in dem ringtauschverfahren ich
glaube nach Griechenland gegangen
insofern ich bin jetzt nicht ganz sicher
wie viele Systeme aktuell die Industrie
schon lieferbar da stehen hat aber das
werden schon einige sein dann wie gesagt
bundeswehrbestände das sind ja Systeme
die sind schon eben operativ einsetzbar
soll heißen soweit ich das sehen kann
ist die Zeit Begrenzung gar nicht mal so
sehr dass diese Systeme nicht zur
Verfügung stehen sondern das Soldaten
also ukrainische Soldaten an ihn
trainiert werden müssen und hier steht
so dieser diese Zeit von 8 Wochen im
Raum das ist acht Wochen dauern würde
die Ukraine zu trainieren also ich denke
ja Frühling märz werden wir die ersten
Systeme sehen und vielleicht wird dann
auch noch mehr nachgerüstet aber also es
wird es wird jetzt nicht morgen sein es
werden sicherlich ja zwei Monate
potenziell sein die es dauert bis bis
die Mörder und die anderen Systeme auch
wirklich in der Ukraine einsatzbereit
sind jetzt gab es zwar hier in der
Community den Vorwurf der Salamitaktik
aber was natürlich auch stimmt ist dass
Deutschland im letzten Jahr immer wieder
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine
geschickt hat erweitert hat gehen wir
mal vielleicht kurz raffen wir zusammen
was war darunter also bislang unter
anderem geliefert Raketenwerfer dann die
Flugabwehr kanonenpanzer Gepard die
Panzerhaubitze 2000 das
Luftverteidigungssystem ihres Tier SLM
kann man denn Deutschland jetzt noch
vorwerfen mit jetzt auch dieser Marder
Lieferung zu wenig zu liefern
ja und nein das ist ganz schwierig
insofern als das wenn man sich die
Zahlen anguckt wenn man auch die Liste
von der Bundesregierung die wurde gerade
auch wieder aktualisiert ansieht von dem
was deutschlandliefert ist es absolut
richtig dass Deutschland sehr viel Macht
drittgrößter viertgrößter militärischer
Lieferer da in Europa klar Deutschland
das ist das größte und wirtschaftlich
stärkste Land in Europa aber da muss man
sich eigentlich nicht verstecken und
auch in der Liste die sie da gerade
angesprochen haben sind viele Systeme
dabei die wirklich relevant sind also
die die Flugabwehr der Gepard die
Panzerhaubitze das sind alles Systeme
die wirklich auch für die Ukraine ja
überlebenswichtig sind das steht auf der
einen Seite auf der anderen Seite und
das ist der Grund warum Deutschland so
stark kritisiert wird die ganze Zeit es
kommt alles immer sehr spät und es kommt
vor allen Dingen so hat man den Eindruck
eigentlich auch nur wenn der Druck von
außen so du groß geworden ist dass man
gar nicht mehr anders kann und das ist
zum großen Teil einfach auch schlechte
politische Kommunikation dass das bleibt
so im in der Erinnerung dass Deutschland
eigentlich nicht will und nur macht wenn
es muss was aber dann teilweise dieser
Debatte übersehen wird ist dass
Deutschland in der Tat eigentlich
einiges macht also da da ist es zum
gewissen Grad einen
Kommunikationsproblem aber trotzdem
Deutschland ist ein wichtiges Land und
Deutschland ist eben auch gerade ein
wichtiges Land was die die Kampfpanzer
angeht ähm Deutschland ist der
Hersteller der Leopard 2 Panzer die in
vielen europäischen Ländern eingesetzt
werden und und einige europäische Länder
würden Sie auch gerne liefern brauchen
dafür aber das Okay von Deutschland also
Deutschland kommt aus verschiedensten
Gründen da eben auch eine Schlüsselrolle
zu und deswegen wird sehr genau darauf
geguckt was Deutschland macht und aus
Deutschland nicht macht und da haben wir
eigentlich seit dem 24 Februar kein
gutes Händchen in der in der
Kommunikation und und erklären auch
nicht wirklich warum manche Dinge erst
nicht gehen und unmöglich sind und dann
zwei Wochen später wenn der Druck groß
genug geworden ist dann eben doch
möglich sind sie haben den Kampfpanzer
Leopard 2 angesprochen wir haben ihn
auch im Bild neben ihnen gesehen das ist
das was die Ukraine auch gerne hätte der
Zweck ist die abwehrfeindlicher
Panzerverbände dazu passt auch eine
Frage bei uns im Stream Seeland 1 fragt
sich braucht Olaf Scholz jetzt wieder
zehn Monate für die Freigabe des Leopard
denn das ist das was die Ukraine als
nächstes fordert
ich würde denken dass die Lieferung der
Leopard-Panzer der Leopard 2
wahrscheinlicher geworden ist ich denke
aber auch das ist sehr unwahrscheinlich
ist dass ich Deutschland in dieser Frage
ja an die Spitze einer europäischen
Gruppe stellen wird die der Vorschlag
der schon länger im Raum steht ist das
mehrere europäische Länder gemeinsam
entscheiden und dann können eben diese
System aus verschiedenen Beständen
kommen Spanien andere Länder das tut
dann den den Streitkräften dieser Länder
weniger weh weil weniger geliefert
werden muss ohne es ist Zeit europäische
Geschlossenheit es ist vielleicht doch
weniger eskalierend als wenn ein Land
das macht das ist so die Idee und
eigentlich müsste der impos davon dafür
von Deutschland kommen und das sehe ich
nicht aber man kann schon denken
Scheibchen Taktik ist es geht immer
weiter und vielleicht reden wir in
einiger Zeit dann tatsächlich über den
über den Leopard 2 wir wissen es aber
nicht also diese Bundesregierung zieht
immer mal wieder so
so rote Linien oder oder sogar zumindest
manche Sachen zu weit gehen und nicht
gehen und dann dann geht einige Zeit ins
Land und dann ist es eben doch möglich
insofern ist auch der Leopard 2 die
Lieferung der Leopard 2 sicherlich nicht
mehr auszuschließen und auch innerhalb
der Koalition wird das ja durchaus
gefordert aber wir wissen es noch nicht
neben dem Leopard 2 gibt es auch den
panzertyp Leopard 1 da möchte Caroline
Neubert Wissen während der Leopard 1
nicht jetzt auch möglich
ja ähm das kann auch genau der nächste
Schritt sein also quasi jetzt erst der
Marder Patriot haben ja auch schon
drüber gesprochen der Gepard ist ja
schon geliefert der nächste Schritt
könnte dann der Leopard eins sein der
auch durchaus helfen könnte der Ukraine
aber teilweise nicht so modern ist
gewisse Neuerungen nicht hat aber das
ist durchaus möglich dass das dann
wiederum der nächste Schritt ist dann
muss man sich aber wirklich fragen warum
dann nicht auf der der Leopard 2 also
das ist das ist eben genau der Punkt mit
diesen
Unterscheidungen seit Anfang des Krieges
hatten wir immer wieder so Diskussionen
in Deutschland die liefern nur defensiv
Waffen keine offensiv nur leichte Waffen
keine schweren Waffen jetzt geht es eben
Panzer aber keine Kampfpanzer diese
Definition die sind immer sehr unklar
und warum man sagt das eine Jahr das
andere nein ist nicht so richtig
nachzuvollziehen und in diese Situation
haben wir jetzt wieder aber ja der
Zuschauer die Zuschauer absolut recht es
kann auch sein dass dann als nächstes
Leopard 1 kommt die die Ukraine möchte
aber spezifisch eigentlich schon die die
Leopard 2 das macht auch für für die
gegen offensiven mehr Sinn man Sachen
wenn wir panzersysteme liefern geht es
natürlich auch um Munition um
Ersatzteile also wie kann das
sichergestellt werden dass es die auch
gibt da gibt es die Frage von User Chris
Watts wie werden die NATO-Länder
sicherstellen dass genügend Nachschub
für die verschiedenen gelieferten
Panzertypen überhaupt zur Verfügung
steht
Munition ist ein riesen Thema schon seit
Anfang des Krieges weil in diesem Krieg
wahnsinnig viel Munition verbraucht wird
auf beiden Seiten im übrigen also die
Zahlen sind teilweise astronomisch und
die übersteigen eigentlich durch alle
Systeme Weg insbesondere auch Artillerie
die Zahlen übersteigen ganz stark die
Zahl die nachproduziert werden kann also
grob gesagt wenn die Ukraine 100 Schuss
verschießt dann kann dem ja eigentlich
nur 20 nachproduziert werden selbst in
Ländern wie in den USA sondern heißen
das ist ein riesen Thema das wurde jetzt
allerdings zunehmend oder wird
allerdings zunehmend ein Thema bei den
ganzen sowjetischen Systemen die ja die
Ukraine auch einsetzt und für die viel
nachgeliefert wurde insbesondere aus
Beständen osteur deutscher starten und
die gesehen sind jetzt teilweise auch
die gehen auch zu neige natürlich stellt
sich dann bei den neuen Systemen
letztendlich dieselbe Frage nach der
Munition ich weiß jetzt nicht wie in in
Deutschland oder auch anders wo der
Nachschub aussieht für Bewaffnung für
den für den oder Munition für den Marder
oder eben auch wie das mit dem Bradley
und den anderen ist dass das kann ich
jetzt nicht sagen aber die Frage wird
sich sicherlich stellen und letztendlich
ja bei allen Systemen ist die Munition
zum gewissen gerade knapp und man
versucht er überall zusammen zu suchen
vielleicht ein Beispiel noch beim Gepard
ist das auch so ein großes Thema und da
hat man dann auch in der Schweiz und
anders wonach gefragt die teilweise
nicht liefern wollten aus
verschiedensten Gründen insofern ist das
sicherlich auch ein Thema was was
aktuell in Berlin und in Paris sondern
Washington diskutiert wird und geschaut
wie man da die nachschuh Wege und den
Nachschub sicherstellen kann dann lassen
Sie uns noch ein bisschen in die Zukunft
schauen also was könnte das jetzt mit
dem Kriegsverlauf machen diese neu
gelieferten Panzer die dann im Frühjahr
kommen sollen verändert das den
Kriegsverlauf wirklich
wie ich vorhin meinte ich wäre immer
vorsichtig zu sagen ein neues System
kommt und dadurch verändert sich jetzt
der ganze Krieg das wäre sicherlich zu
viel zu sagen es gibt ein paar Variablen
die relevant sind und ja die
Verfügbarkeit für die Ukraine von was
diese Panzer angeht ist schon ein Punkt
das kann und wird die die gegen
offensiven denke ich ähm stärken das ist
sicherlich wichtig die andere Frage ist
allerdings wie sieht es auf der
russischen Seite aus und ähm auch
Russland hat Probleme mit Equipment mit
Soldaten sowieso es sie könnte sie so
aus als würde Russland z.B auch die
Artillerie Munition ausgeben ausgehen
jetzt wird aber auch darüber berichtet
dass sie Attraktion aus Nordkorea
bekommen soll heißen die Frage der
Unterstützer wird zunehmend wichtig die
Ukraine hat auf ihrer Seite die Nato und
und den besten die da eben helfen
darüber haben wir die ganze Zeit geredet
und jetzt ist die Frage wo kann Russland
noch Unterstützung herkriegen und und
der Iran ist dann ein großes Thema wir
haben ja viel über iranische Drohnen zum
Beispiel gesprochen Nordkorea mag jetzt
ein anderes sein wenn Russland in der
Lage ist dann zunehmend auch Munition
und anderes zu kriegen dann wird das den
Krieg verlängern und dann bedeutet es
dass beide Seiten der Meinung sind sie
können militärisch da das gewinnen wenn
es dazu neige geht könnte es eben auch
dazu kommen dass das ist letztendlich zu
dem Stillstand kommt und dann auch ja
möglicherweise zu einer Situation in der
Verhandlung möglich werden das ist
unglaublich schwer vorauszusagen aber
ich denke schon dass jetzt die die
Lieferung dieser Panzer eben der Ukraine
mit ihren gegen offensiven also der
Zurückeroberung des das von Russland
besetzten Gebietes helfen könnte und vor
allen Dingen und das ist eben auch ganz
wichtig einfach helfen kann die
ukrainischen Soldaten zu schützen und
sicher zu gehen dass das die nicht mit
umgepanzerten
teilweise Autos auf dem Schlachtfeld da
unterwegs sind
dazu fragt sich anonym ob es denn
bedenken gibt also immer wieder wenn
auch gezögert wird gibt es bedenken dass
nato-technik in russische Hände fallen
könntest das ein zögerungsgrund
diese Debatte gab und gibt es bei sehr
modernen Systemen ich kenne sie vor
allen Dingen zum Beispiel was
amerikanische Drohnen angeht da wurde
mal darüber gesprochen dass man bei
Eagle Drohnen ist ein relativ neue
System an die Ukraine liefern könnte und
da ging es so ein bisschen in die
Richtung man will nicht dass das
Russland in die Hände fällt das wäre
sicherlich auch ein Punkt was sie nicht
Flugzeuge angeht bei diesen Panzern
insbesondere System wieder Marder die
jetzt ja weiß Gott nicht neu sind ist
das meines Wissens nach kein kein großes
Thema das sind jetzt Jahrzehnte alte
Systeme da haben wir schon neueres
geliefert insofern an da denke ich das
nicht aber im Hintergrund so ganz
grundsätzlich was die Waffenlieferung
angeht überlegen natürlich die
Partnerländer schon was will man liefern
was könnte Russland in die Hände fallen
und wie würde das z.B auch gewertet von
russisch russischer Seite wenn dann
jetzt auch noch einen Kampfpanzer wieder
Leopard 2 geliefert wurde
letztendlich ist ja die Antwort des
wissen wir nicht
diese
es gibt ja eben Sorge das gewisse Dinge
in eskalationsschritt sind das ist aber
nicht mal unbedingt das Russland das
sagt das ist teilweise von uns selbst
gegeben
genau wissen wir es nie letztendlich ist
klar Russland und Putin hat diesen Krieg
begonnen sie könnten ihn zu jedem Moment
beenden und es liegt halt an ihnen was
ihrer Meinung nach in eine Eskalation
der der westlichen Seite ist wir haben
die Reaktionen jetzt von zumindest von
russischen Botschaft in Berlin ähm
gehört irgendwie weil wir uns danach
richten wollen ist überhaupt noch eine
andere Frage
wir wissen es nicht ich es ist jetzt
aber auch nicht so als hätten wir gehört
Leopard 2 ist die klare Eskalation im
übrigen vielleicht noch ein Punkt wenn
dem so wäre wenn wir wissen Russland ist
da ganz besonders reagiert ganz ganz
besonders drauf kann man natürlich auch
damit durchaus kann man das auch nutzen
indem man sagt gut
hier wenn ihr dieses und jenes nicht tut
zum Beispiel eben zurückziehen auf
gewisse Linien dann liefern wir den
Leopard also quasi dass man dass man
damit auch umgeht aber letztendlich wie
können die die Reaktionen aus dem Kreml
aus Moskau nicht nicht vorhersagen auch
die hängt sicherlich immer sehr von der
aktuellen Situation ab insofern würde
ich sagen wir dürfen uns auch nur zum
zum gewissen gerade überhaupt daran
hängen und und davon abhängig machen
wir wissen jetzt also was an westlichen
Waffen jetzt in naher Zukunft kommen
wird dann zum Schluss die Frage was hat
Russland denn selbst noch an Waffen
entgegenzusetzen dann
ja russland hat Russland ist ein großes
Land die Sowjetunion hatte ein
unglaubliches Arsenal an an Waffen da
wird jetzt viel von
aufgebraucht ich hatte vorhin
angesprochen das ist auch ein
wahnsinnigen Verbrauch an zum Beispiel
eben Artillerie Munition gibt da sieht
es jetzt schon so aus als würden auch
Russland die die Systeme und und die
Munition ausgehen deswegen auch eben das
hinwenden an zum Iran nach Nordkorea und
und anderswo aber sagen wir mal so wir
können jetzt nicht darauf spekulieren
dass das Russland die die Waffen
ausgehen weil ich fast sagen hat
Russland eher ein Personalproblem nicht
so sehr in der Anzahl sondern in der in
der Qualität ähm aber
da ist leider in in Russland noch
einiges da gerade im übrigen auch Panzer
diese werden hatte hatte mich 10.000
Panzer ähm dass da das ist nicht als
sein die dann morgen quasi als wenn sie
morgen zu Neige gehen
ein Schätzungen von Sicherheitsexperten
Ulrike Franke heute abend vielen Dank
für Ihre Zeit schönen Abend
und damit sind wir am Ende von unserer
Sendung ein letzter Kommentar von Timo
Davids der schreibt wir brauchen
humanitäre Hilfe und wiederaufbaufonds
in diesem Krieg der bald ein Jahr dauert
wir wollen jetzt aber damit schließen
für heute Abend vielen Dank für eure
Fragen für eure Aufmerksamkeit dass ihr
dabei wart habt einen schönen Abend ein
schönes Wochenende bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss